[Music]
i have a ridiculous story here about
this man
and i'm sure you can assume where he's
from china
it's a very it's a very common phrase
like florida
yep ah a florida man a florida man
he eats gator hot dogs that sounds
delicious that's delicious actually
do they when they're telling a news
story though about a crazy chinese
person are they like
china man
[Laughter]
yeah okay a chinese man yes yes yes i
see that a lot nice
yeah would you generalize it to what
province are the provinces those are
states and
like a wuhan man yeah of china yeah yeah
it's maybe it's the wuhan
china is the florida to the world no so
yeah okay a florida man here
he set his own truck on fire
because apparently according to him he
says that he wanted to give deputies
something to do
because they were bored because he
thought they were bored
wait he told them that when they
literally told him that very considerate
of him yeah
he probably drove by some deputies
eating donuts and he's like damn
yeah i feel so bad doesn't he think by
doing that he's giving firefighters
something to do
it's like the wrong people right that's
good
i don't even think of that yeah his
brain doesn't work very well maybe he
thought that the cops will come and go
oh [ __ ]
let's call the fire department and then
that's where that's their job do you
think when the fire department comes
he's like oh [ __ ] i was trying to get
the cops
but he's getting arrested he's like oh
yes it worked this time
yeah yeah
yeah so this is his truck that he set in
flames how did it flip over though
so it actually exploded oh [ __ ] like an
action movie
yeah it's a michael bay show like a
nearby building and stuff
and um another picture i was just trying
to do a good thing
look at his face oh wait no wait for
this photo you said there's a
firefighter there's back there
yeah goddammit this one why you guys
here oh i see it here oh yeah i couldn't
see it for a second and then you're
saying
i was just trying to do a good thing
yeah he looks he looks like i'm not
he feels like i'm not appreciated i need
shampoo guys
no it's a thanksless thankless he's like
but now i get to give the jailer
something to do
my ass yeah he's very giving the inmate
something to do too
inmates but yeah so i mean from
from the look on his face can you maybe
get an idea as to what might
be methamphetamines thank you he's not
chinese though if that's what you're
thinking
no i wasn't no he's powered by meth why
did you say he was a chinese man at the
beginning
so yeah so this this guy here so his
name is kevin he's 28 years old
he his truck was a 2002
chevrolet silverado i get it now why
no it's a waterfall it probably burned
on his own
like chevy's you know yeah shots fired
yeah so
that's sponsored by twitter oh wait do
you have a chevy yeah
because it's breaking down i'm not
breaking down uh
i had an oil change that's normal i
haven't
my car's at 40. well toyota's do
whatever the [ __ ] you do whatever the
[ __ ] you want
i've never gotten an oil changing
microphone big brag
what kind of car is it i don't know it's
an electric car
or something yeah something like that my
car is old
your car's dope though thank you
it still doesn't need anything done
that's true
it's it's that 268 000 miles and you
drove to utah
back from a road trip yeah all you got
to do for toyota's it's just the oil
change man
yeah how many how many gallons per mile
for the mile miles per gallon
okay so it's like it's like 16. that's
good
and then top mileage is like 75 miles
per hour i have big rigs telling me
like hey go faster but the cool [ __ ] is
i think like the way that it like like
you can really
appreciate it is is off the road like
when you're on dirt and [ __ ] you're just
like oh my god like
it's really living and breathing now
because it's four wheels right
yeah it's four wheel drive special
suspension where it doesn't like
rock your car a lot i i mean it bounces
but it feels great like it's funny
does it feel better than a newer car
that's built for off-roading
uh i don't know because bart's off-road
is like doesn't even feel like you're
off-road
like it's still an old car right it's
it's a 1988
but it feels like it can take on
anything like i got stuck the wheel was
covered in like mud and i was like how
am i gonna get out of this and we're
like oh wait we didn't turn on the
four-wheel drive and then we turned it
off we locked the wheels we just got out
of it like nothing
how fun and then so we started going
from hot spring to hot spring
like we didn't have to people had to
drive to the main road
and then go up to the parking lot we
would just go straight from one to the
other
in between the snow sick yeah at any
moment did you feel like i want to burn
this car down
to get some deputies jobs well
you forgot about that part that's in his
past maybe if i saw
uh uh that was sad i've explored i'm
excited
i'm so thankful though that i never got
addicted to the crazy [ __ ]
because i've tried every drug known to
men except for heroin and shrooms
oh thank you quite an accomplishment
right
yeah you should say gateway drug not to
you pal no
and that was one of my life goals too i
think i set a new year's resolution when
i was 14 i was like you know what
i'm gonna try to do drugs every single
day for 365.
what they're going to be high on
something did you get did you
i did that was my first uh things that
i've accomplished for a whole year wow
yeah i was high every single day on
something
what has that and one day i'll be like
oh i'm sober i got to find something to
get high
on you know and i'll be like get drunk
or something like is that your go-to
yeah like
i would drink i would smoke weed i just
loved experimenting with like different
things
i i didn't i didn't really see it as
like wrong
you know what i mean like you tell the
kids like don't do certain things and
then all the people that are rich and
like
successful have done they go they do
cook well they've done it in their past
you know
don't do drugs [ __ ] well
i mean now you're painting it in a way
where it's like because of
a lot of these kids they're successful
but that's false nadine it's not false
listen
does the plot of one of my favorite
movies flight if he didn't take the
cocaine
very true so sick and the plot one of my
favorite movies drunken master
if you didn't get drunk you would not
beat the bad guy
and the plot of drunken master ii was
exactly the same plot
i noticed that well anyway so back to
this kevin dude so they're saying that
when he was placed in handcuffs
and the deputies searched him they found
a glass pipe used to smoke mess
of course in his pocket and a folded up
dollar bill with traces of meth in his
wallet
and um again so when he was talking to
officers he was just like yeah i just
wanted to have
i just wanted um to give something
for you guys to do like i just wanted to
see my tax dollars at work
i'll do a little math oh this is his
actual quote he said
he or like the the sheriff's office
quote
he wanted something for the sheriff's
office to do and he wanted to give
himself an early christmas present so he
set his truck on fire
i don't get the christmas present maybe
he wanted to get a new truck i wonder
what he said
i wonder what he said the next day
[Laughter]
the way he set his his truck on fire
though is that he poured
gas inside of the cabin under the trunk
uh the truck very thorough and then he
created a trail away from the car
like the movie fire did he flick a
cigarette
i walked
i've always wanted to do that though put
some sunglasses on while you're walking
yeah that is pretty cool i saw a
youtuber from russia recently do it to
his
car i was like i forgot how much money
but it was like stupid expensive
all right oh the mercedes one yeah it
wasn't mercedes we actually covered it
okay exploded yeah because it kept
breaking down on him
and he was just like you know what [ __ ]
it i'll just make a youtube video out of
this i saw rachel's like oh i
got to put gas in it [ __ ] it yeah my
favorite thing about that
i think i recorded it you know every one
of the comments was like why didn't you
just give it to me
oh yeah that's how i feel sometimes too
when i see things going aways i'm like
oh i would i could have had it like did
you know in uh the middle east there's
like
ditched lamborghinis in the desert
that's just chilling there i've seen
pictures of it
wait why so basically in dubai
like saudi arabia if you owe a debt it's
uh you go to jail and you're in jail
until you can pay it off
so sometimes when these people like how
do you make money in jail that's that's
why so that's why they just ditched the
car and flee that's why there's so many
at the airport oh
[ __ ] and also the other reason is
because there's so much money sometimes
they're like
instead of fixing i'll just buy another
one yeah like it gets stuck in the sand
and then they're just like ah [ __ ] well
i know that it's not meant for
off-roading a lamborghini yeah what the
[ __ ] yeah but there's so much
i saw them like ghost riding a [ __ ]
lamborghini and like doing donuts with
it in the desert
and then like it got stuck and then i
was like damn i wonder if they're gonna
like keep it or not dude i knew a chick
who had a prius
it had a little ding in the side of the
door she's a ritz chick
and her dad bought her a new prius from
just a thing like that just from the
ding like that wow
that's like that's how much money just
the
billionaires have or like the rich rich
have like
i could do that with maybe a t-shirt
wait so you know like oh [ __ ] burger if
there's hair
i pull the hair out
no wait if they're that rich though why
are they leaving it in the desert
like can't they pay off their debt like
i don't understand so
there's two different things there's
probably other reasons but if they're in
debt they go to jail
and they they're in jail until they can
pay it off so those are not non-rich and
the second reason is when it gets stuck
in the desert they buy a new one because
they're so rich don't you understand
right now
because the rich rich rich are just like
oh
i got sand in my car let me get three
more there's definitely other reasons
too but these are like some of the most
common ones yeah cause like we hear
stories of like
mega rich chinese that go into a shop
and then they're like
oh i like this watch uh how many do you
have and then they'll be like oh
we have like eight of them i'll take
them all wow so no one else can have one
yeah reason yeah yeah they'll be like i
wanna i wanna have all the different
colors
and and so like i have the exclusive but
each watch is like 10 or 20 g's
like i'll just take eight of them they
take the whole stock
so it's just a different mindset because
like
i have that when it comes to ooh these
cupcakes are amazing
i'll take eight so i could take it to my
friends all right
i'm like at least i'll take your whole
stock you know someone waiting in line
was like oh i wanted another blueberry
cupcake
and i'm like sorry buddy those rich
chinese guys
he's just one of those rich chinese
taking all the blueberry cupcakes
getting us getting [ __ ] behind someone
there's different levels you know right
there's like i'm like that level dude
i'm like my level is going to the vegas
with the face and taking all the crab
legs
you are that chinese guy i'm that
chinese guy all the asians
that's a billionaire to like broke it's
all the same
you